well let's let's pull up the uh the
bigger story in this in this whole whole
thing uh shout out to andrew kerr of the
washington examiner investigating this
black lives matter has shut down
fundraising days after liberal states
threatened legal action
we don't know who's in charge
we don't know where the money is
apparently they went to the address that
blm files and there's nothing there and
the people there are like i have no idea
you're talking about there's no blm here
yo it's almost like
blm is a shadow organization that never
really existed so what is it is it a
charity blm well it's like wait are
there so the people who are encouraging
american citizens to burn down their
communities are sketchy this is crazy no
yes yes
so if they start a charity black lives
matter i imagine it's a 501c3 i'm trying
to figure it out i think it says it is
and then what happened all these
chapters started spawning well there's
black lives matter there's local
chapters because anybody can make a
local whatever they want and they're not
charities but they probably are so they
might be charities too yeah but it's the
the black lives matter global network
foundation that's like the official
organization yo you've got california
saying like where's the money and they
went uh
indiana says it's a scam the indian ag
was like it's
he's like it's it's indicative of what
scams do i'm looking at it's a house of
cards there's the black lives matter
foundation which is not the black lives
matter movement it's also a foundation
of 501c3 december 19th was formed and
it's been taking donations there's an
advisory from buzzfeed nbc is like watch
out for the black lives matter
foundation because it's not affiliated
with the movement uh so there you're
starting to see like money grab
fraudulent scams pop up at least in this
instance yeah so this is it right here i
pulled it up the black lives matter
global network foundation former
executive director was patrice cullers
everybody knows her because she's that
lady bought all those houses right yeah
three i think three or four houses she
had five oh wow yeah she had five and
they were they were you know they were
they were up there huh and it's a 501c3
and currently it has non-profit
compliance issues
wow yeah well they're not disclosing the
finances they're not disclosing the
numbers they're supposed to have public
records of what is happening with that
money they're preventing people from see
it and and and when journalists are
asking about this the people who are
initially asked about this are now
trying to conceal their information or
hide who they are to not even be held
accountable for this as the california
department of justice is literally
threatening these leaders saying that
they could be held personally liable if
they don't disclose the financial record
let me let me just read this let me just
read this for you guys all right you you
guys are ready for this one let me build
a little bit of suspense from
influencewatch.org
purchase of former communist party of
canada headquarters
in july 2021 the non-profit m4bj
purchased a 10 000 square foot mansion
in downtown toronto did they take the
toilets out formerly served as the
headquarters of the communist party of
canada according to the washington
examiner the bulk of the 8.1 million uh
purchase price came via a restricted
capital grant provided by the blm global
network foundation where'd your money go
they took over the communist party
headquarters in toronto well this is
what i find so hilarious tim earlier you
were talking about the intelligentsia
and it is true according to pew research
that people who have higher education or
have been through higher education are
more likely to support blm but one thing
i find very interesting about that is if
this is a movement which is more likely
to be supported by really intelligent
people how did none of them figure out
that it was such a scam
it's very funny because in this country
probably over the past 100 maybe 150
years our notion of what education is
supposed to be changed so in the past it
was something that was set aside for a
very small minority of people who could
handle things like learning greek and
latin by the time they were 16 years old
and who would be completely familiar
with the entire western lexicon and then
would go on to higher learning
now i think it's great that we have
widespread literacy and we've increased
access to education but when it comes to
higher education we've just tried to
funnel everyone through it even though
the entire model that was created
initially was for the particularly and
really highly intelligent and so what's
happened is we've dumbed down higher
education to the point where the people
who go through it can't even spot that
something like this is an unbelievably
obvious scam it's not that they can't
spot it it's that even just basic
questioning of the institution and the
organization labeled you a racist
labeled you as someone who was
intolerant labeled you as someone who
was bigoted when when you didn't support
these marxist ideas you were of course
attacked viciously by a lot of powerful
organizations and institutions that were
just blindly writing checks to these
organizations so that had a huge social
factor to it yeah no but and i would
even question the validity of that study
myself personally yeah so i i think it's
it's both i mean you're absolutely right
that they're not allowed to question it
but i think part of the reason they're
not allowed to question is because
higher education no longer has the same
message it used to which is that we
should be questioning things we should
be trying to discover new ideas and this
should be reserved for very intelligent
people who are actually capable of
wrestling with ideas and aren't just
going to go along with the group you
guys so that the whole whoopi goldberg
thing was started over the mouse book
and kill a mockingbird getting removed
from the curriculum
the new york post even claimed mouse was
banned it's literally not true so i've
got a couple points to make this is fun
so i was on facebook and this lefty guy
i know he like posted hey look they
banned mouse and then linked to a story
and i responded with they didn't ban it
they just took it off the curriculum and
the response was that means the school
banned it no and then i responded with
the gulag archipelago was also banned
and they all went whoa really and i was
like that's right
because it's not in their curriculum
that means it's banned isn't it yeah so
i saw another post right and it's this
meme going around many of you may have
seen it where it's a stack of books and
all of these banned books and it's from
like occupy democrats or something and
it says kids listen if anyone tells you
that you don't that you you can't read a
book you need to find this book and read
it and decide for yourself my response
was absolutely we should be sending kids
the book rigged by molly hemingway yeah
so they can learn about the election and
if anyone tells them they shouldn't read
it that's proof they should irreversible
harm and then it's actually funny
because i saw that post i saw that meme
and one of the books in the meme was
like the joy of sex and it's like yeah
before a certain age you probably
shouldn't be reading that but they're
not banned books it's not no i know so
so they told me you know these these
books aren't
these books are banned and i was like
when i was a kid a banned book meant if
you brought to school they'd take it
from you and call your parents
they'd be like this is inappropriate for
kids you should not be showing this and
usually it was like serious adult stuff
that's a banned book when they're just
like we're not going to make it required
reading but we don't care if you have it
in the library if you want to read it
but it's not banned no but this is uh
how did we how did we get into the book
thing again i don't know well we were
just talking about higher education and
how totally failed in this country is
that being intelligent and educated
doesn't mean that you're moral
a lot of really intelligent people do
really immoral things like they're not
scientists for instance but maybe blm as
well i don't know well i would consider
it i agree completely but i also think
that's a product of the fact that in
some ways we've reclassified what it
means to be intelligent so historically
and i think if you look at like aquinas
or aristotle their definition of
intelligence was that you were able to
see the world for what it was and then
act in accordance with it and now we've
changed it to more or less refer to
people who have something approximating
g which is what we usually talk about
when we're talking about iq like their
their ability to wrestle with
abstractions
and notice patterns their working memory
that kind of thing and those are all
really important and they're strongly
correlated with with economic success
but
intelligence in the classical sense also
does include a person's ability to
behave virtuously because virtue is just
acting within reasons rather than
choosing short-term pleasure which is
more intelligent i want to think of it
like that that bell curve meme of the
really dumb person midwit and then like
the smart person
and it's like the really really dumb
person understands you know the the
many of them not all of them there's a
dunning-kruger effect but they're like
you know in
when you're smart you can make things
work and you can figure it out they're
really really smart people understand
this but people in the middle are like i
went to school therefore i'm smart
exactly that their whole the whole basis
is
we're we're the better men because those
truckers never graduated college exactly
the non-college educated you know it's
really funny when the left mocks the
non-college educated working-class
people
because they do dumb things i'm like the
funny thing is
those truckers those trades men and
women the people working for the fire
department for the police department
other organizations have experienced the
real world to a to a substantially
larger degree than college kids and they
make their decisions and actions based
off real life and these college
graduates have never actually
experienced real life and they live in a
bubble where they think they're smarter
than everybody but could not make they
they would never be able to figure out
how to make a rudimentary machine they'd
just be like i don't know the government
should do it for me shame is just really
quick the system the education system
rewards people who are indoctrinated
successfully and are able just to
regurgitate and repeat the talking
points that are told to them and this is
why walmart goldman sachs the cia all of
them were singing the praises of blm and
their virtues and their marxist ideas
they were like this is a great idea the
cia even went on a tirade promoting
black panther has some kind of woke
ideology which is absolutely crazy and
mind-boggling so so these are
regurgitators and repeaters i and i
would even question that kind of mark of
intelligence myself no i would agree
with you completely i mean so the
average college
graduate has an iq of about 114 so
that's i mean that's a bit above average
but that's by no means exceptional so to
boast i graduated colleges if that's any
kind of accomplishment anymore is
absolutely ridiculous and to look down
on your average working person who's
like likely just as smart as you and
certainly has more knowledge of the
world than you do is completely
ridiculous i feel ashamed that i went to
college i feel strange that i went into
that too but i went and i wasted my time
with your time there sheamus no no no
honestly i don't know i'm very i'm
actually very i was privileged to be
able to go on i'm very glad that i was
able to go but it's true like to brag
about it to like look down on people
because you have a college degree and
they don't is absurd because basically
anyone can get a college degree nowadays
i
i
still
can't
write and spell and i have a college
diploma it's like you don't have to be
smart you know to graduate college you
don't want to fill out fill out the
dotted line and hand in the paper 150
and just repeat what the professor tells
you to repeat here's what here's what i
i just find
i find it kind of sad because i really
want to help people succeed like
when people come to me and they ask me
for real advice i'll i'll tell them like
here's the best advice i can give you
you know there's a bunch of other people
who know stuff i don't know i was on the
phone earlier with another big you know
independent media organization asking
them for advice
and uh i see these people on twitter and
they like to you know these people with
almost no followers
who just complain about the government
all day and stuff and i'm like i kind of
got no problem they're coming out
they're playing out the government's
complaint about the wrong thing but they
make fun of people for not being college
educated and they specifically come
after me for not finishing high school
and i'm just i want to stop and ask them
like what is the point of your life like
what are your life goals do you want to
fit in do you want to look around the
room and say i've accomplished something
to you is that having a degree
because to me i don't care what you
think i just care about doing cool stuff
you know what i mean so so as i'm
growing up i never saw the point of how
a degree or diploma would do would do
anything to help me achieve my goals and
my dreams and these people who pursued
that are now laden with student loan
debt they want the government to pay it
off for them and they're insulting me
for running a successful business
because i didn't finish high school it's
completely backwards i think they
genuinely do not understand what life is
and so they just complain and they're
scared and confused well there's a
there's a way that the system coddles
kind of comfort and and makes you
adverse to any kind of uh you know
things that you have to actually work
for and whether it's just blinding
yourself with pleasure or entertainment
or video games the system right now is
literally i believe priming you to live
in a box to be a part of a vr metaverse
technological world where you have all
your pleasures just delivered right to
you when it comes to actually
sacrificing when it comes to actual hard
work when it comes to actual pain that
those are virtues that are not taught to
individuals they're they're they're in
our society it's it's looked upon as
something negative but it but it's
something that of course makes life as
amazing and it's worth living for with
those things in it yeah i would also say
this when people sort of look down on
you for your level of education even
though you have a very successful
business there's something ironic about
that because particularly with the
purpose of modern education it's more or
less to get people credentialed so that
you can predict their future success so
to say well you don't have the predictor
of the success that you ended up having
is a backwards way of looking at it
i think at this point and i've talked a
lot about it higher education is
basically just it's put people in this
isolated space where they become
indoctrinated not necessarily on purpose
i know there's a lot of professors that
do try to indoctrinate obviously but
when you take a bunch of people and put
them in an environment where they're not
actually going to learn anything
meaningful for the most part i mean
obviously they might learn about the
great works and and the great quotes but
i mean can they fix a toilet can they
can they repair their car can they
balance a checkbook did they learn
fights a lot of people go to school for
things that don't make sense no yeah so
so what happens when you take all of
these people put them in this room they
develop no meaningful skills release
them into the world they're confused why
they don't fit into society and they get
angry about it they demand the
government change everything for them
but if they did the system would
collapse because these are not the
people propping the system up you want
to know who's propping the system system
up very very obviously i know it it's
almost at nauseam at this point truckers
transferring the goods carpenters
tradesmen contractors plumbers
electricians
all like i tell you man
get any degree in the world you want
you will you will need a plumber
a hundred times more often than you will
need someone with a degree in you know
from a liberal post-modern literature or
something yeah like i i read marx and i
read
all of these great works about communism
i'm like can you fix my toilet or not
dude i don't know what to talk i'm
wondering i'm thinking about the
difference between iq and eq that's
intelligence quotient and emotional
quotient and kind of how the idea of
intellect is you could probably divide
it into both and i wonder if it's the
struggle of the blue-collar work that
develops eq that it's the pain of like
having to do something you don't
necessarily want to do that you learn
like
how to deal with emotions eq's gonna
stop you right there no i gotta stop you
right there what do you mean you don't
want to do what does that mean like it's
it's it's stressful jobs that are
stressful what
a job that is stressful is the job that
you don't want to do and that could be
any job in the world well like this job
is not stressful to me i used to chop
wood that was really hard and that's for
you and there are a lot of people i know
that are like i could never sit in a
seat and talk about this kind of stuff
i'd be so embarrassed and insecure i'd
rather just chop wood man i know i know
people who work hvac who are like i
tried doing other stuff but this really
is where i just feel the most useful
like when we have a contractor come in
here and you get a guy who's like a just
like a regular you know
laborer
and he doesn't know anything about hdmi
cords or 4k or whatever and then he's
like oh you got a support problem in
your wall i'm like please help me
because i have no idea how to fix that
that's that's a person who's passionate
about their job who says i can solve
this problem for you they feel good
about their job
anybody can feel good about their job
the issue is we're taking these young
people we're putting them in colleges
and telling them to be astronauts and
rock stars y'all should have watched
fight club because tyler durden told you
right then that's not what you're going
to be learn something meaningful mike
rowe says it i want to push back a
little bit he said don't follow your
passions follow what do you say follow
your talents i said don't follow your
passion let your passion follow you
basically take your passion with you to
whatever job yes right yeah right right
i think you know we have too many people
who want to be
acknowledged
but but they want to be on tv they want
to be influencers they want all the
likes but you could just be a really
really great electrician and then you go
and work a job and you're gonna have
some family and they're gonna be like
you are a life saver we had no idea what
the problem was that the refrigerator
went out our food was spoiling
he came in snapped his fingers and
solved all of our problems lifesavers
just really quick don't watch fight club
if you're in china because the
government there just edited the ending
of it but second of all uh you know life
has a lot of ups and downs it's a crazy
ride but they're trying to incentivize
that it's only going to be up but again
you can't have the up if you don't have
the down but but this is why the world
economic forum a part of their 2030
pledge for not owning anything not
having any privacy was also that you'll
be happy this is what the system uses in
order to incentivize everyone because
they make you miserable on purpose they
create the circumstances in your life
where you are indebted unhappy
unsatisfied and a little worker be slave
for their establishment and then they're
like but we'll give you all the
happiness just give us more of your
liberty more of your freedom whatever
your responsibility don't you don't have
to you don't have to sacrifice and work
hard those are bad things and when you
teach people not to sacrifice not to
work hard you literally create little
lemmings you create the perfect slaves
are going to be perfect for the
establishment
to have as their little peons to do
whatever they wanted to do with because
then you get rid of personal
responsibility in people's internal
strength but let's let's let's have an
honest conversation about this right
when you have an ever increasing quality
of life when people today live better
than you know the richest people 100
years ago when your dental care is
better than rockefellers when your
cancer treatment is better than
rockefeller's and all the you know the
the oil barons and the rubber barons or
whatever
at a certain point
that kind of increased
quality of life it can't sustain itself
so what i think happens is you end up
with these these millennials who are
told life will be better than it was
than your the the life your parents led
your life will be better
now it's not as good but it's all
relative you know what i mean 100 years
ago if you took a poor person and
brought them into the average apartment
with clean running water hot water air
conditioning and a refrigerator they'd
be like you must be a billionaire like
wow or a millionaire because of
inflation it wasn't as high that back
then but they would think you were like
a king it's like no no this is just
everybody gets it so what's happening
with the global elites is to try to take
all that away from you so they can
trickle it back really slowly it's the
idea that harry tubman said harry tommen
said i freed many slaves i would have
freed many more if only they knew they
were slaves they take away all of these
luxuries from you
then once you have nothing
they'll make you happy by giving you
point one percent back
and it's it's worse than just taking the
lectures right now well this is why they
talk about population control all the
time sorry and you know oh yeah i don't
i think not only do they
relieve you of your luxuries but they'll
induce suffering and then remove a
little bit of suffering and call it
happiness
but it's relative so
covet happens they destroy everyone's
business they make everybody
uncomfortable and angry people start
losing their minds crime skyrockets
now they can go we'll save you and they
slowly starbucks they cause the problem
make you angry once you get used to it
they reduce the problem they cause a
little bit and you feel a little bit
more relieved you see how that works
call that happiness that's right
fleeting they say you're happy now right
you're happy well this is why they've
been trying to restrict people's ability
to travel to eat red meat and to live a
life of freedom and personal
responsibility because when you have
that they have less themselves and
they're utter control freaks a lot of
them are sociopaths they believe in this
unrealistic idea of population control
and population reduction for the
betterment of the world which is
absolutely a ridiculous idea that has
been debunked by many different
scientists and different studies and
different data sets already out there
but they still keep pushing it as if if
it's the norm and now they're trying to
push an agenda where we destroy the
family unit because when we destroy the
family unit there's going to be a lot
less people out there which means a lot
more resources for the billionaire class
a lot less for everyone else because
they're not reproducing i was kind of
thinking that um
with the current economic trajectory
we're on for globally with china set to
take over
maybe a lot of these elites have just
said you know why resist it who cares
who's in charge as long as they protect
themselves and their assets and so it
kind of feels in many ways
there this may be good for americans in
the long run
bad in a lot of ways but good a lot of
ways that we get our freedoms we we
restore you know balance in this country
but china does take over and then it
asserts you know serious authority over
the rest of the planet but i kind of
feel like
it's possible that trajectory for
china's rampant growth is inevitable
and that's why it's like we're kind of
just spinning our wheels here you know i
see it differently just really i just
really wanted to make this point because
it just brought so many important
aspects that i really just want to talk
about really quickly you know there's a
reason henry kissinger and david
rockefeller opened up china to the rest
of the world there's a reason
individuals like bill gates and other
multinational billionaire corporate
entities are the one advising china and
propping up china to be as powerful and
as prominent as they are right now and
and i think it's it's not what you said
tim that i see it differently i see it
as the corporate elites trying to bring
in the chinese model into the rest of
the world so we are uh under a social
credit score we are living like we are
in china with the government
centralizing controlling every aspect of
our existence i think that's the end
game i think that's where they're trying
to go and i think covid was an excuse
for them to try to initiate a lot of
their programs and initiatives in order
to make that happen sorry go ahead you
know i i also wouldn't assume that china
is together enough to have any real
long-term success their economy is
developing right now but first of all
they're going to hit a birth dirt they
already have had a birth death because
they don't they don't have
enough women to
insell apocalypse yeah they're going to
have their in-cell apocalypse they're
not going to be having children at a
proper replacement rate and you've sort
of mentioned how that could be grounds
for some kind of conquest for them but
there's only so far you can go with that
i genuinely believe that the more
comfortable china becomes the more their
citizenry is going to become like our
own in many ways and i'm referring
specifically to the unfortunate aspects
of our citizenry they're not going to be
as interested in virtue or
self-development or even in family and i
think their system is going to rot
within and then we on the other hand
will likely face some very difficult
times and i think that's going to result
in the average person becoming more
virtuous and so there really is cause
for hope here thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 pm and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time
you